la doctrine zombie qui semble ne jamais mourir,
peu importe qu'elle soit entièrement discréditée.
Vous avez peut-être imaginé que la crise financière de 2008
aurait mené à l'effondrement du néolibéralisme.
Après tout, elle a exposé ses caractéristiques clés,
qui étaient de déréguler les affaires et la finance,
de détruire les protections publiques,
de nous mettre en concurrence extrême les uns envers les autres,
comme étant, eh bien, quelque peu déficientes.
Intellectuellement, il s'est effondré.
Mais il domine encore notre vie.
Pourquoi ?
Je crois que la réponse est que nous n'avons pas encore élaboré
une nouvelle histoire avec laquelle le remplacer.
Les histoires sont nos moyens de navigation dans le monde.
Elles nous permettent d'interpréter ses signaux complexes et contradictoires.
Quand nous voulons comprendre quelque chose,
le sens que nous cherchons n'est pas du sens scientifique
mais de la fidélité narrative.
Est-ce que ce que nous entendons reflète la façon
dont nous nous attendons à ce que les humains et le monde se comportent ?
Est-ce que cela tient la route ?
Est-ce que cela évolue
comme une histoire devrait évoluer ?
Nous sommes des créatures de récit
et une série de faits et de chiffres, peu importe leur importance --
je suis un empiriste, je crois aux faits et aux chiffres --
mais ces faits et chiffres n'ont pas le pouvoir
de supplanter une histoire convaincante.
La seule chose qui puisse remplacer une histoire
est une histoire.
Vous ne pouvez pas ôter son histoire à quelqu'un
sans lui en donner une nouvelle.
Ce ne sont pas les histoires en général dont nous sommes à l'écoute,
mais des structures narratives spécifiques.
Il y a un certain nombre de synopsis élémentaires
que nous utilisons et réutilisons.
En politique, il y a un synopsis élémentaire
qui s'avère être incroyablement fort
et je l'appelle « l'histoire de la réhabilitation ».
Elle se déroule ainsi.
Le chaos accable la contrée,
causé par des forces puissantes et néfastes
œuvrant contre les intérêts de l'humanité.
Mais le héros va se révolter contre ce chaos,
combattre ces forces puissantes,
contre toute attente, les renverser
et rétablir l'harmonie dans la contrée.
Vous avez déjà entendu cette histoire.
C'est l'histoire de la Bible.
C'est l'histoire de « Harry Potter ».
C'est l'histoire du « Seigneur des anneaux ».
C'est l'histoire de « Narnia ».
Mais c'est également l'histoire
qui a accompagné presque toutes les transformations politiques et religieuses
depuis des millénaires.
En fait, nous pourrions aller jusqu'à dire
que sans une nouvelle histoire de réhabilitation percutante,
une transformation politique et religieuse
ne pourrait pas se produire.
C'est aussi important que cela.
Après l'économie du laissez-faire qui a déclenché la Grande Dépression,
John Maynard Keynes a écrit de nouvelles sciences économiques
et ce qu'il a fait, c'est raconter une histoire de réhabilitation
et l'histoire était la suivante.
Le chaos accable la contrée !
(Rires)
Causé par les forces puissantes et néfastes de l'élite économique
qui s'est emparée de la richesse mondiale.
Mais le héros de l'histoire,
l’État catalyseur, soutenu par les gens des classes ouvrière et moyenne,
contestera ce chaos,
combattra ces forces puissantes en redistribuant les richesses
et en dépensant l'argent public pour des biens publics,
générera des revenus et des emplois,
rétablissant l'harmonie dans la contrée.
Comme toute bonne histoire de réhabilitation,
celle-là a résonné dans toute la sphère politique.
Les Démocrates et les Républicains, les Travaillistes et les Conservateurs,
la gauche et la droite sont tous devenus, globalement, keynésiens.
Puis, quand le keynésianisme s'est heurté à des difficultés
dans les années 70,
les néolibéraux, des gens comme Friedrich Hayek et Milton Friedman,
se sont manifestés avec leur nouvelle histoire de réhabilitation
et l'histoire était la suivante.
Vous ne devinerez jamais.
(Rires)
La chaos accable la contrée !
Causé par les forces puissantes et néfastes
de l’État omnipotent
dont les tendances à la collectivisation écrasent la liberté, l'individualisme
et les opportunités.
Mais le héros de l'histoire, l'entrepreneur,
va combattre ces forces puissantes,
faire reculer l’État
et en créant de la richesse et des opportunités,
rétablir l'harmonie dans la contrée.
Cette histoire a résonné dans toute la sphère politique.
Républicains et Démocrates, Conservateurs et Travaillistes,
ils sont tous devenus, globalement, néolibéraux.
Des histoires contraires
avec une structure narrative identique.
Puis, en 2008,
l'histoire néolibérale s'est effondrée
et ses opposants se sont manifestés ...
avec rien du tout.
Pas de nouvelle histoire de réhabilitation !
Le mieux qu'ils avaient à offrir était un néolibéralisme édulcoré
ou un keynésianisme réchauffé.
Et c'est pour cela que nous sommes coincés.
Sans cette nouvelle histoire,
nous sommes coincés avec l'ancienne histoire défaillante
qui continue de défaillir.
Le désespoir est l'état dans lequel nous sombrons
quand notre imagination défaille.
Quand nous n'avons pas d'histoire qui explique le présent
et décrit le futur,
l'espoir s'évapore.
L'échec politique est en son cœur
un manque d'imagination.
Sans histoire de réhabilitation
qui puisse nous dire où nous devons aller,
rien ne changera,
mais avec une telle histoire de réhabilitation,
presque tout peut changer.
L'histoire que nous devons raconter
est une histoire qui séduira un éventail de personnes aussi vaste que possible,
au-delà des lignes de fracture politique.
Elle devrait résonner avec des besoins et des désirs profonds.
Elle devrait être simple et intelligible
et elle devrait être ancrée dans la réalité.
J'admets que tout ceci semble être un défi de taille.
Mais dans les nations occidentales,
il y a une telle histoire
qui attend d'être racontée.
Au cours des dernières années,
il y a eu une fascinante convergence de découvertes
dans différentes sciences,
en psychologie, en anthropologie, en neuroscience et en biologie évolutive,
et elles nous disent toutes quelque chose d'extraordinaire :
les êtres humains ont cette incroyable faculté à l'altruisme.
Bien sûr, nous avons tous un peu d'égoïsme et de cupidité en nous,
mais chez la plupart des gens, ce ne sont pas nos valeurs dominantes.
Nous nous avérons également être les coopérateurs ultimes.
Nous avons survécu aux savanes africaines,
malgré le fait que nous étions plus faibles et plus lents
que nos prédateurs et que la majorité de nos proies,
grâce à une faculté incroyable à nous aider mutuellement.
Et ce désir de coopérer a été programmé dans nos esprits
via la sélection naturelle.
Ce sont des faits essentiels et cruciaux au sujet de l'humanité :
notre altruisme et notre coopération incroyables.
Mais quelque chose s'est terriblement mal passé.
Le chaos accable la contrée.
(Rires)
Notre bonne nature a été contrecarrée par plusieurs forces,
mais je crois que la plus puissante est le récit politique dominant
de notre époque,
qui nous dit que nous devrions vivre dans un individualisme extrême
et en concurrence avec les autres.
Cela nous pousse à nous battre, à craindre et à nous méfier des autres.
Cela atomise la société.
Cela affaiblit les liens sociaux qui font que notre vie mérite d'être vécue.
Et dans ce néant,
ces forces violentes et intolérantes s'accroissent.
Nous sommes une société d'altruistes,
mais nous sommes gouvernés par des psychopathes.
(Applaudissements)
Mais cela n'a pas à être ainsi.
Cela n'a pas à être ainsi
car nous avons cet incroyable potentiel d'unité et d'appartenance.
Et en faisant appel à ce potentiel,
nous pouvons recouvrer ces formidables aspects de notre humanité :
notre altruisme et notre coopération.
Où il y a de l'atomisation, nous pouvons établir une vie civique florissante
avec une culture participative riche.
Où nous nous trouvons écrasés entre le marché et l’État,
nous pouvons établir une économie qui respecte les gens et la planète.
Et nous pouvons établir cette économie
autour de cette sphère remarquable et négligée :
les biens communs.
Les biens communs ne sont ni le marché ni l’État,
ni le capitalisme ni le communisme,
mais ils consistent en trois éléments principaux :
une ressource spécifique,
une communauté spécifique qui gère cette ressource
et les règles et négociations
que cette communauté développe pour la gérer.
Pensez à du haut débit communautaire,
à des coopératives énergétiques communautaires
ou à un terrain partagé pour cultiver des fruits et légumes,
ce que nous appelons jardins familiaux.
Un bien commun ne peut pas être vendu ou être cédé
et ses bénéfices sont partagés équitablement
entre les membres de la communauté.
Là où nous avons été ignorés et exploités,
nous pouvons raviver notre politique.
Nous pouvons reprendre notre démocratie des gens qui s'en sont emparés.
Nous pouvons utiliser de nouvelles règles et méthodes d'élections
pour nous assurer que le pouvoir financier
n'éclipse plus jamais le pouvoir démocratique.
(Applaudissements)
La démocratie représentative devrait être tempérée par la démocratie participative
afin que nous puissions raffiner nos choix politiques
et ce choix devrait être exercé autant que possible au niveau local.
Si quelque chose peut être décidé localement,
cela ne devrait pas être déterminé nationalement.
J'appelle cela la politique d'appartenance.
Je pense que cela peut être attrayant
auprès d'un large éventail de gens
et la raison en est que parmi les quelques rares valeurs
que la gauche et la droite partagent,
il y a le sentiment d'appartenance et la communauté.
Nous parlons peut-être de choses légèrement différentes,
mais commençons au moins avec quelques mots en commun.
Vous pouvez voir beaucoup de la politique comme étant une recherche d'appartenance.
Même les fascistes sont à la recherche d'une communauté,
quoiqu'une communauté effroyablement homogène
où tout le monde se ressemble, porte le même uniforme
et chante les mêmes slogans.
Ce que nous avons besoin de créer,
c'est une communauté fondée sur l'interconnexion de réseaux,
pas l'unification de réseaux.
Un réseau unifié réunit des gens issus d'un groupe homogène,
alors que des réseaux interconnectés
réunissent des gens issus de différents groupes.
Je suis convaincu que si nous créons
des communautés interconnectées riches et vivantes,
nous pouvons contrecarrer le désir des gens de se terrer dans la sécurité
d'une communauté homogène
se défendant contre les autres.
Pour résumer,
notre nouvelle histoire pourrait se dérouler comme suit.
Le chaos accable la contrée !
(Rires)
Causé par les forces puissantes et néfastes
des gens qui disent que la société n'existe pas,
qui nous disent que notre objectif le plus noble dans la vie
est de nous battre tels des chiens errants pour une poubelle.
Mais les héros de l'histoire, nous,
nous nous révolterons contre ce chaos.
Nous combattrons ces forces néfastes en créant des communautés
riches, stimulantes, inclusives et généreuses
et, ce faisant,
nous rétablirons l'harmonie dans la contrée.
(Applaudissements)
Que vous ayez ou non l'impression que c'est la bonne histoire,
j'espère que vous serez d'accord qu'il en faut une.
Il nous faut une nouvelle histoire de réhabilitation
qui va nous guider pour sortir du pétrin dans lequel nous sommes,
qui nous dit pourquoi nous sommes dans le pétrin
et qui nous dit comment nous sortir de ce pétrin.
Cette histoire, si elle est racontée correctement,
pénètrera les esprits des gens dans toute la sphère politique.
Notre tâche est de raconter l'histoire
qui éclaire le chemin vers un monde meilleur.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)